passwords for pain its optimization with
upper confidence Frank law thank you
very much thanks for the invitation as
well it's a great pleasure to speak in
such a cool workshop so today I'm going
to talk about a generalization of multi
unbanded problems and one way to solve
this problem I should say that this is
joint work with Geneva she and I should
also say that he's the one who sent me
this picture so since this is a
generalization of multi unbend it's I'm
just going to start by recalling what
this means at least from our point of
view so we're going to consider the
stochastic case and so this means that
at every round you choose one of K
actions so in a case you know this can
be slot machines or one unbanded hence
the name of the problem and each of
these action is associated to a
distribution new I with some unknown
mean mu I okay and the principle of the
bandit feedback is that when you play
one slot machine you only observe the
feedback from this slot machine so you
observe the feedback drawn from the
distribution new ID when your choice is
a policy by T in between 1 to K right
with meanness me up I'd so of course the
idea is to minimize the cumulative loss
or its expectation right you want to
lose as little money as possible in a
casino and so if you take the average
it's equal to this or if you take the
expectation if you take the
corresponding means you get something
like this and then one point of view is
that this can be treated as a stochastic
optimization problem right of course you
don't know the Meuse if he knew them in
advance you just always pick the action
that corresponds the smallest loss but
if you don't the idea is that you can
rewrite this function in this way right
so if you don't sum over time but sum of
all the actions this is equal to UI
times the number of times you've played
action I and since you're taking an
average you can write it like this as
well right geology
all right so if you look at this
variable this is a vector in the simplex
in the unit simplex and you can write
your loss in the multi-armed bandit case
as just a linear form like this on the
simplex and and so now you can see the
multi-armed bandit problem as a
stochastic optimization problem where
you try to minimize linear form on the
simplex with an unknown vector okay and
so you have you have this picture this
the the minimum is here this would be
the best arm and you can measure your
pseudo regret this would be equivalent
to an optimization in this case right
and the important thing is that the
feedback that you get on the unknown
knew is tied to this variable PG right
so it's not like in stochastic
optimization in general where maybe you
get independent gradients at every step
independent information on the whole
vector mu if you never play this action
and so the variable is always here you
don't you all you only know about the
variations of the functions on this line
you never know that how much it varies
here all right so if you're playing this
game here this could be really bad
because this means that you will never
know anything about the fact that in
order to minimize it you need to go
downhill you need to go there so there's
really a link here between and all these
banded partners between what you play
and what you know about the function
okay and so in this case the objetive
optimization problem is very simple
there's one by section and this is the
action that you should always play but
in order of situations let's say you're
going into a supermarket your utility
function is not linear there's not one
best product and you should not fill
your basket only with this product right
and there's many other applications like
this right so going with the supermarket
example imagine that there are key goods
in the supermarket and your objective is
to maximize some unknown utility
function
let's say it has some unknown parameters
beta I so this is known as a cop do
class utility function and you can
rewrite it you can rewrite it as
equivalently minimizing some loss on the
simplex by taking this loss okay and so
the idea is that every time you put
something in your basket you have some
you know looking at your basket some
evaluation of how much more happy you
are with this item in your basket and so
you have you observed some noisy change
in utility
we've mean beta of PI G right what PI T
is equal to some I write for only one of
those for only the object that you put
in your basket all right so now this
becomes a different stochastic
optimization problem still on the same
variable but with a different function
and now the optimum is not going to be
in a corner it's somewhere in the middle
of the simplex and if you knew the beta
rise in advance you could compute that
it's equal to that but if you don't know
at all the beta is or don't even know
that your utility function looks like
this you only see some noisy change in
utility then the question is how can you
how can you fill your basket optimally
with only this noisy feedback and again
here the information on beta is linked
to the variable P right if you never buy
one of these products you never know
about so this is now what the
corresponding picture would look like
this function is not a linear form
anymore the minimum is somewhere in the
middle and this is a simple example for
problem where you don't have one optimal
action but there's an optimal strategy
that's just optimal weighting of all the
actions and then again now this is a
stochastic optimization problem with a
convex function on the simplex with some
unknown beta and so there are many other
ways to see applications of these types
of a problem like this the one that
first brought me to this was linked to
statistics the idea is that you're
trying to estimate some unknown vector
theta
you have key sources that correspond to
each of the coefficients and they each
have a different variance Sigma I square
okay so now if you have first-year
undergrad you can ask them what's going
to be the expectation of the loss of the
very simple estimator and you'll find a
sequel to this if you have second-year
undergrad you can ask them to find the
optimal TI so that you minimize this
they will find that the optimal TI are
proportional to Sigma I and if there's a
bad source this means you should sample
more from this source and so this is
equivalent to minimizing a loss function
of this type there are other problems
sequential resource allocation your
government sending teachers in one
region and you get a noisy feedback of
whether or not there's less or you
should you should send more or less
teachers in that region so you can
phrase a lot of optimization problems
like this where you have an unknown
function L on the simplex and it's
unknown because it has some unknown
parameter vector parameter with one
coefficient associated to each action
and the feedback on the parameter is
tied to the variable PT and if you've
played some action a lot of times this
means that your estimation of this
particular coefficient is more accurate
and again you have some optimum P star
somewhere in the simplex and you have
some optimization error that looks like
this okay so to formalize all of this
now I've given a bit of motivation the
problem is that you have an unknown
convex function L on the simplex at each
round you much you must choose one
action and only one and at each round
you're observing a vector GT which is a
proxy of the gradient the idea is that
the I've coefficient of GT is going to
be an estimate of the I've coefficient
of the gradient with a precision that
depends on the number of times that
you've played the action I so far right
this is this capital T I of T all right
so this doesn't come from you know
over hat this is motivated by all these
parametric settings and so the objective
of course is to choose your actions in
order to minimize this loss and the
performance of any policy because
there's randomness it's going to be
measured by the expectation of error of
peaty compared to the minimum right are
there any questions about the setup and
opponent so the natural question is how
do you solve this there's one before
that there's a comparison review so the
idea is how is this different from
vended problems first it's really
different because the loss is not
cumulative and you're not looking at an
average of losses at each action you're
looking at the loss at the average of
all the actions right so there's no
natural notion of regret yeah
again there's no individual best action
if you have a natural notion of regret
there's one best action here it's not
the case there's an optimal mixed
strategy and how is this different from
stochastic optimization well it's
different because you can't choose a new
constraint you can't choose a new
variable XT at each at each round it's
linked to all your actions before that
this is this vector PT of proportions of
each action and it cannot be chosen
freely in your domain and the gradient
feedback that you're getting is also
tied to these actions it's not
independent stochastic so really you
have a lot of constraints on this
stochastic optimization problem does
existing work that is a bit similar to
this where there are linear banded
problems with non convex loss but it's a
little bit less general so again the
take-home message of this problem is
that you have the rules of banded
problems when trying to do stochastic
optimization right so it's a real bit
more constrained okay so how do we how
we do we have watch this how it we are
trying to solve this problem the idea
first is that when you write just a
dynamic of the poem right just looking
again at the words of the game what
happens when you choose the next action
time T plus 1 you have this equation for
how your point is going to move alright
so this is you know just writing the
definition of PG + PT plus 1 and when we
first wrote this we thought okay this
looks a lot like some sort of gradient
type update right where you're doing a
step in one particular direction and in
particular because now this is this
point is a corner of the simplex it
looks a lot like Frank worst type update
all right so the Frank Wharf algorithm
is a type of algorithm to minimize
convex functions on on convex sets with
nice extreme points the idea is not to
step in the direction of minus the
gradient but to find the extreme point
that's the most in the direction of the
gradient right by solving this linear
problem and then to step in that
direction right so to take a convex
combination of X T and C T plus 1 all
right so here if this one known in
advance all right so if we knew the last
function we would have Franco would just
tell us well this is the new action that
you should take you know the gradient so
you should take the extreme point that's
gone that's the most going to be in the
direction of minus the gradient of X and
the big issue is of course here that we
don't know error all right so yeah so in
this case we will just do this in this
case we just do this with this step size
which we just mean taking the I such
that the I've coefficient of the
gradient is minimum and for a C smooth
convex function we would get a guarantee
of this type right we get convergence of
order log T of it so now if we have an
unknown function but we have some sort
of stochastic gradient instead of having
the gradient as an information the first
idea is to just plug in the stochastic
gradient in this problem so now of
course people
familiar with my charm and it's already
know that even if this is a linear
function this is a horrible idea the
issue is that if you always take the
action that you think is the best right
now you might be very unlucky on the
best action in the beginning and so this
means that you're never going to pick it
again
and you're going to have horrible you're
going to have horrible rates of
convergence it's not going to go to zero
so the usual fix in multi unbend it is
to correct for uncertainty
you don't look only at the gradient that
you have but you look also at the
physics that is the set of statistically
feasible gradients in some sense all
right so you look you take into account
the uncertainty so you take a valid
confidence interval or region for any
for any coefficient and in the case of
multi unbounded so the gradient is just
going to be mu and the estimate of the
gradient is just going to be this vector
of estimated new hat and so you just
correct by the size of the confidence
interval right so this is like taking
the estimated vector and adding a vector
of uncertainty and then you solve this
and since 2002 we know that this has
some really nice performance okay so our
idea was well to do this and to
generalize it to a Francophile : and so
to take a frank warfare go even and to
update and to plug in not only the
estimated gradient that we have but an
estimated gradient corrected for
uncertainty okay so this is the upper
confidence Frank wall Falco even the
idea is that at each round we observe
this noisy estimate of the gradient we
correct for certainty so this should be
GI of liturgy and then we select the
action such that the coefficient of this
vector is the lowest right so we're not
only guided by the gradient we're also
guided by the uncertainty the idea is
that here we want to promote exploration
yeah
this is making the assumption that the
gradients are founded in between zero
and one
nope but then how is this an actual
conference bound for you guys you know
we have some variants one we this is so
this is the assumption that so we have
some yeah yeah we have some assumption
that we have some noise so so really on
you motivated some of this by using the
example of utilities you know TV the
power beta so this is not an uncertainty
on P this is a certainty on bit all
right so the idea is in this example
let's say you get some noisy estimate of
beta at every time this is motivated by
the change in the log of the utility but
we also in the people we have cases
where it's not only sub Gaussian like
any kind of really generic decreasing
function here I'm just presenting the
natural case when it's one of us curve
of Ti
so here the assumption is that really
this is a very confidence interval
that's like in the description of the
powder and so yeah so we're promoting
exploration by adding this if we omit
grading computations this is very simple
at every round we just need to update
our vector compute new confidence
intervals and then just take the lowest
of these coefficients and then the
update is just happening naturally and
so the proof elements for this link
elements from convex optimization and
some elements of the proof for you CDs
yes I'm just going to go quickly over
this the idea is that if we just take
the proof of the Frank war factor even
with known gradients and the C smooth
function and we adapted the ideas that
we are going to obtain an air which has
the optimization term and also a term of
errors right so this is just the error
of choice the fact that you haven't
chosen you haven't actually chosen some
action that's that's the action that the
Frank were fico is and we tell you to do
all right so in the multi-armed bandit
case this is just the difference between
the two means the one that you've
selected and the best one and in general
this is less than the coefficient of the
gradient that you've chosen minus the
actual lowest coefficient right so this
is really the difference between what
you would have done if he knew the
gradient and knew what you have done
instead
okay so similarly adapting the proof of
the you see B of the you see I'll go
ahead for multi unbend it we obtain the
slow rate under very general condition
here just assuming that the function is
convex and C smooth right so we have
statistical term that dominates and we
have something in square root of Lochte
over G okay so in the linear case if the
function is linear this matches the
result of UCD so and actually the
algorithm is
do you see the algorithm so this is just
a frank work type type proof of the rate
of the Eusebio algorithm and up to
logarithmic terms
it matches the actual lower bound in
this problem so now if we make some
small improvements by adding some
conditions and looking at instance
dependent rates we can get faster rates
so in multi unbend it's that's already
known if you have gaps between the
smallest loss and the losses of other
actions that are bounded away from zero
you can improve this to a fast rate
something in 1 over T times something
that's dependent on the gaps if this
goes to 0 it will blow up but if it's
bounded away from zero that's fine the
idea is you just do some simple
algebraic manipulation based on
cauchy-schwarz inequality because you're
bounding initially the number of times
you've played the wrong actions the idea
is that the general lower bound is built
on a case where you have this type of
gap so this is a situation where the
function is flat enough maybe between
two points so that you're statistically
confused between these two points and at
the same time the difference is large
enough that this is actually causing you
a problem of order 1 over square roots
and it also has a nice geometric
interpretation in the simplex corner
this is just saying that minus the
gradient is going in this cone in the
corner of the simplex the KKT conditions
already our design you that this is
going to be non-negative but how how it
is bounded away from zero how the Delta
is a bounded away from zero describes
how deep this negative gradient is in
the corner and so we can extend this to
cases where the function the loss
function is minimized in a corner and
where we have gaps on the coefficients
of the gradient and so by doing
essentially the same proof except here
that this is an approximation on
inequality we have this type of result
and you can see that as the function
gets flatter and flatter and the
negative gradient gets closer to the
boundary this mean
that this is more and more true this is
more and more easy to agitate between
these two corners that's the geometric
interpretation okay so we have fast
rates if we make additional assumptions
but this will be only for now in cases
where we are in a corner right when
there is one optimal action and this is
the one that you should choose but in
the beginning and you spent all this
time explaining that what we're actually
interested in situations where there's
one optimal mixed strategy that's in the
inside of the simplex and and the idea
is that if the function is allowed to be
very flat that's going to be a problem
so we look at what happens if the
function is not allowed to be flat
anymore we consider mu strongly convex
functions right so there's always a
quadratic term in this inequality and
cases where the minimum is bounded away
from the boundary of the simplex by some
parameter ETA all right so this is just
saying essentially that the we leave
some room around the minimum for this
inequality to make sense to be usable
this is a very classical hypothesis in
stochastic optimization and also in the
analysis of Frank Wharf so there's many
other people and this we've looked at
that but usually in banded type problems
more classical bandit eye problems this
is not always exploitable and so we
didn't know initially if this was going
to be exploitable if we're going to get
faster rates in this problem it turns
out that it is actually possible the
idea is that there's a convexity bound
that we are using everywhere in our
proof that can be improved under
conditions where you have strong
convexity and the minimum is bounded
away from the boundary so this is a
lemma from Lacoste jr. and yogi that's
hidden in the paper but very useful and
from this we can guess fast rate for MU
strongly convex function with interior
minimum with the same algorithm we we're
not telling the algorithm that the
function is strongly convex the truline
proof idea that takes more than 20 pages
is that essentially these are the
epsilon cheese
and so now if you replace them if you
replace the inequality by your square
you have something that looks more like
this if the epsilon T's are decaying
fast enough and the slow rate initially
already implies that you're already same
using each action more or less up to
some square with the appropriate number
of times so the precision because it
decays like 1 over square root of Ti
decays also like 1 over square root of T
and so essentially it works and you have
squares which means you have a one of it
here instead of having a one square
think this is for T large enough and K
is fixed in offsetting so we look a
little bit at the dependency in K but
yeah you have to be able to play every
one at least once but we haven't
optimized this so the summary is that in
general for nishijima functions these
are the result that you get if you make
an additional assumption because this is
optimal so I have a corner condition or
which is something that's a little bit
more suited to our setting a strong
convexity within to a minimum assumption
you can get faster rates so for in the
first case this is optimal up to lock
terms with linear forms and in this case
as well now the question is is this
optimal as well so the answer is again
yes up to rock terms and this is done by
looking at the family of functions so
quadratic forms that are minimized at a
point that's close to the minimum and we
look at a lot of these functions and we
show that in all model it's going to be
hard to distinguish between any of these
functions based on the observations
which means that it's hard to optimize
this is the classical way of doing lower
bounds in stochastic optimization if you
could optimize your functions it means
that you could solve a statistical
problem well and in this case there's a
lower bound so it leads to a lower bound
of this type which you can compare with
all upper bound so initially this was a
bit worried
to me because it looked like a
upper-bound was beating the local bond
and what I realized is that actually
this is not a parameter like 1/2 this is
the distance away from the boundary and
in the simplex this needs to be smaller
than 1 over K right so actually we
realize that we have a pretty bad
dependency on K and this is something
that we could optimize something else is
that in offsetting we have a direct link
between action and observation right so
if you play action I you observe
something about the I parameter natural
question is can this be relaxed to a
mixed bandit feedback this would be in
particular interesting in adaptive
sampling and experiment designs in
general if you make no assumption this
can be this can be pathologically bad
even in dimension 3 the idea is that
even for so strongly convex functions
you can look at a function of this type
where in order to optimize the first
time you need to know theta 1 and the
only way to get information about theta
is to play the third action and so in
this case very naturally you can show
that you get a lower bound of 1 over T
to the 2/3 which is much worse inant I
think still that this is an interesting
question and I think that if you make
additional assumptions such as you know
you're learning from you're learning
from the parameter I a little bit at
least when you're playing action I the
way to learn about our matter is not
only to play over actions I think that
this can be improved
ok and so to conclude this is a new
model that links stochastic optimization
and then deponent generalizing
multi-armed bandit I think it's a
natural playground for a lot of
applications and to consider other types
of problems such as online experiment
design and also what I like was the
solution was bridging these two domains
that we're using ideas from the two
domains and the proof also I was just
using ideas from these two domains and
way that we get adaptive fast rate so
does
ways to design algorithms that would
work well in a lot of these other
conditions but this works well for
everything without knowing essentially
anything about the function there's lots
of open questions if you're interested
in this so if you think you have ideas
about this I'm very interested in
talking to you and I guess everyone's
looking forward to lunch so I'm just
going to multiplicative I we haven't
considered that but I think I think it
would be possible because essentially
these types I think these types of down
the exists for Frank Wharf and so I
think if you just translate that into
this theory I think this would work as
well I'm not absolutely sure but we
haven't thought about it
so the question can you so here you had
a I guess it was going to be the
parametric assumptions that you always
have the same confidence no matter where
you're actually for your gradient yes
you can you think of setups where this
is actually would be the case so for the
first question I think it's possible to
change it so we've considered just
general functions we've considered
general functions where you can change
the way it depends on TI but what you're
asking is actually this right if it
depends on the whole trajectory so we
haven't we thought about this a little
bit but we haven't pushed it because so
to answer your second question we're not
able to think of motivations for this
all right so the bells tell us that it's
lunchtime so we'll see each other
[Applause]